welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead season 11 the final season
and the best way to celebrate the end of
the main Walking Dead series is to get
some sweet official merch from The
Walking Dead shop stick around after the
recap I'll be unboxing this quarter
Supply Dropbox let's find out what's
inside season 10 ended on a cliffhanger
when Eugene and his crew were ambushed
by the Stormtrooper looking guys now we
learn they're from the Commonwealth it
is a massive successful survivors
community that seems to be a nice happy
place now remember the reason Eugene
came here is for a booty call with
Stephanie His Radio girlfriend who turns
out is real she wasn't catfishing him
but the arguably more important reason
they came here is to get help for
Alexandria it's in pretty bad shape
remember the whisperers trashed it last
season and the most urgent problem
they're running out of food but now
Maggie is back on the show and she's
like hey the settlement I just came from
had a ton of food unfortunately it was
taken over by the Reapers so the group
sets off on a mission and coming with
them is Big Bad Negan he's been on a
Redemption Arc the last few seasons but
Maggie hasn't seen that and is still
real mad at him for killing her husband
Glenn and there's no time to argue
because more Walkers coming for him
Maggie's got no choice but to work with
him to survive but the Danger's not over
cause now they're ambushed by the
Reapers our group is all separated
naturally Negan and Maggie end up
together but luckily father Gabriel
shows up to mediate along with Maggie's
one surviving friend Elijah who is the
cool guy in the mask with the ninja
skills but he's not a Mandalorian who
has to keep his mask on he takes it off
instantly like Oh I'm a normal dude
meanwhile Daryl is separated looking for
his best friend dog who has been picked
up by a Reaper but turns out Daryl knows
this Reaper because it's Leah yeah
remember from the season 10 bonus
episode she was Daryl's girlfriend and
dog's original owner she takes him back
to the reaper compound turns out the
Reapers were her original crew Daryl's
like hey babe that's cool I didn't even
know those guys so I'll join you so they
give him the reaper entrance exam and
Daryl passes so he gets to meet the
leader of the Reapers Pope as you might
expect he is a psycho megalomaniac who
believes the Reapers were chosen by God
why is it so hard to meet normal people
in the zombie apocalypse then there's a
really memorable episode featuring and
Connie The Walking Dead goes full horror
for an episode when they take shelter in
this haunted house and thou are chased
by these creepy crawling zombies those
aren't zombies these are living people
that have just gone feral and turn to
Gollum from Lord of the Rings now back
to the Commonwealth Stephanie agrees to
help sneak him into the radio tower so
they can contact back home but they
gotta watch out for the orange power
ranger chief of security Mercer it's
princess who takes Point distracting him
basically by hitting on him but that
doesn't distract him for long they're
caught and in big trouble their lawyer
is Lance Hornsby who is basically
exactly Better Call Saul and he gets him
off with just community service clearing
out Walker Duty now back to Maggie's
Mission which is down to just four
people negan's like hey I have an idea
to get reinforcements from the Walkers
oh Whisperer style Maggie and Negan the
new Alpha and beta so now it's time to
reveal himself hey sorry girl but I'm
with them the Reapers suck you should
join us Lee is conflicted what's he
gonna do but just then Pope unveils the
Reaper's secret weapon but Lee is like
whoa if you fire this thing you'll hit
our brothers who are down in the mix
fighting and Pope's like hey if that's
God's will then that's what it is so now
it's time for the Daryl Pope Showdown
but it's actually Leah oh who gets him
in the back Daryl's like awesome I'm
glad you joined the light side but Leah
is not joining him she's like Pope had
to go but the reapers are still my
brothers I'm sticking with him oh she
pulls our kylo Ren killed snoke but
staying on the dark side the Reapers
fall back wait did we win no you did not
kylo Leah's just pulled him back so she
can fire the huacha but you know none of
our characters get hit long story short
we fight to a stalemate with just a few
members on each side Leah calls in her
sniper on the roof but that's not her
man it's father Gabriel who went in for
the priest fight with the Reaper's guy
and took him out Daryl channels his
inner Rick Grimes the living are all on
the same side and Maggie agrees to let
him go but then Maggie remembers how
they slaughtered her entire community so
she changes her mind and kills the
remaining Reapers no mercy Leah escapes
when Daryl lets her go but operation
food run is a huge success except almost
everyone who came died including Alden
by the way R.I.P Alden as for Maggie and
nigas negan's like look mags this group
apparently isn't big enough for both of
us I'll just be on my way and Negan
leaves the group back at Alexandria
things have been rough they're barely
holding it together but now our crew's
back and for the first time this season
everyone's reunited but wait what's this
who's coming now a bunch of Stormtrooper
yes Eugene finally talked to the
Commonwealth about helping Alexandria
and now Lance hornsby's like hey uh this
place has seen better days we're happy
to help you rebuild but also anyone who
wants can come join us in the
Commonwealth it's a survivor's community
on a level we've never seen before
apparently they've got 50 000 people
it's a real City the leader of the
Commonwealth is Governor Pamela Milton
who seems like a nice person but our
crew doesn't have the best track record
with Governors Carol has put back on her
Meek housewife cookie baking persona but
she's watching everything real close
everyone's assigned to jobs based on
what they were before the zombie
apocalypse Daryl and Rosita didn't
really have jobs before so they joined
the military their skills are killing
Walkers Daryl gets on the bad side of
the incomparable douche that is the
governor's son Sebastian Milton normally
Daryl wouldn't put up with this he'd
just go off and live as a wood permit
again but with Rick and Michonne both
off the show Daryl's taking in their
kids Judith and RJ so he needs that
Stormtrooper money to provide for his
family and that is the secretly devious
part of the Commonwealth they're not
cannibals they just use money and
they've got a massive wealth gap between
the Haves and have-nots yumiko who is a
fan Nancy Harvard lawyer gets to come to
fancy parties while her girlfriend
Magnus serving the drinks anyone who
stands up like we are the 99 gets
immediately shut down to Pamela Milton
they are more dangerous than the zombies
but for the most part life in the
Commonwealth is really good especially
for Eugene with his lady loves Stephanie
turns out she's just an agent working
for her boss Lance Hornsby who is in
charge of the Commonwealth CIA he put
her undercover to learn this group
Secrets but turns out they don't really
have any so hey bro sorry we broke your
heart but just as Eugene's feeling real
bad he hears a familiar voice that knows
he's in Stephanie's radio call signs
turns out this is the real Stephanie
she's Pamela Milton's assistant we've
seen a few times although Stephanie was
still a fake name her name is Max but
everything else was real she built a
secret radio and really liked Eugene but
having a secret radio was very illegal
so Mercer her brother kept her out of
trouble by setting him up with the fake
Stephanie thing she's like bro how could
you not know that wasn't me but he's
like hey a hot girl liked me I wasn't
gonna ask questions and so these two
work it out and truly fall in love
speaking of romance princess continues
sitting on Mercer and he's into it these
two start dating now back at Alexandria
where Aaron is the leader these days and
the Commonwealth really is help and
rebuild but Maggie has gone back to
Hilltop and they're offering to help her
too but she turns him down she sees
right through the Commonwealth's class
system BS and wants no part of it but
Lance Hornsby really wanted to make the
steal happen because theoretically if
the Commonwealth has colonies he could
become the regional governor and now we
start to see Lance hornsby's crazy side
oh we thought he was Saul Goodman looks
like he's Littlefinger so one day Aaron
and Gabriel are recruited for an
Outreach mission to this community that
lives in an apartment building it's okay
guys the Commonwealth's real cool we
have ice cream and stuff but oh their
boss starts shooting people up yeah the
Outreach mission was just a cover for an
extermination Mission so as this guy
starts executing civilians Aaron and
Gabriel take a stand against it now
they're under arrest but they're rescued
by none other than Negan yes this is
where he wandered off to it's only been
six months but Negan has a girlfriend
here in fact they're married in fact
she's pregnant my man Negan moves quick
long story short he gets a message to
Maggie so she comes to join the
apartment resistance but her son
Herschel stowed away and now he's
captured by the Commonwealth so uncle
negan's got a bus down there to save him
now I call him Uncle Negan these days
but you got gotta remember he was a
monster who brutally murdered herschel's
father but he finally shows some real
remorse like Hey kid I'm not that guy
anymore so they put this beef on hold so
working together Our Gang takes these
Commonwealth soldiers out and this guy
Carlson ends up eaten by the people he
pushed off the building back at the
Commonwealth Daryl's playing nice with
Sebastian Milton so one day he takes him
out for an off the books Mission he
wants them to break into the zombie
infested house where his friend used to
live and he knows his dad had a bunch of
cash in the safe yeah remember the
Commonwealth uses American currency so
cash is still King but turns out they're
not the first people Sebastian sent he
sent a bunch of random civilians who
were deep in debt and desperate and that
goes beyond off the book's mission for
Commonwealth soldiers he's fully just
sending poor people to their deaths
Mercer followed him here they explained
the situation he doesn't confront
Sebastian and start a whole thing but
he's now disillusioned with Commonwealth
leadership but the rest of our crew is
ready to expose it along with reporters
Connie and Kelly who have already been
working to expose Commonwealth
corruption what they need is some hard
evidence and Eugene knows someone who
can help his girlfriend Max Pamela
Milton's assistant who has also become
disillusioned realized Pamela Milton
only cares about money and Max steals
some files that it's enough to print an
Expose and the star part of the
Commonwealth revolution has started but
meanwhile Lance Hornsby goes in person
to find out what happened at the
apartment where Aaron and Gabriel play
it cool with the cover story he knows
they're lying though and suspects that
Maggie at the hilltop was involved and
so this is where we get the standoff
Maggie versus Stormtrooper Daryl but
when tensions get high Daryl proves he's
on Maggie's side and Lance is like whoa
I don't want to fight we'll leave you in
peace but on the way back it becomes
apparent that our crew's been Marked for
Death so oh it turns into one Epic
shootout so Maggie takes the fight to
the Commonwealth soldiers but she's
ambushed and captured by Reaper Leah yes
Lance Hornsby found her hanging around
like hey wait you want Maggie dead I
want Maggie dead let's work together and
so it's the final Maggie Leah fight in
the end Leah has the upper hand but oh
she's shot by Daryl yes who chose his
best friend Maggie over his
ex-girlfriend Leah and so our crew
escapes for now but Lance Hornsby is not
happy he decides to occupy Hilltop fly
in the Commonwealth flag and he occupies
Alexandria too no more foreign aid
you're now a commonwealth colony and
don't forget Oceanside is our third big
Community Lance Hornsby rounds everyone
up and flips his lucky coin oh man is he
turning into a two-face would he execute
all of Oceanside but we don't find out
what happened at Oceanside for now Lance
Hornsby is still hunting our crew down
they need to warn the others still
inside the Commonwealth so they send
someone the Commonwealth's never met
before yes it's Negan who goes inside
and tells Carol what's happening inside
the Commonwealth it's protest time after
Connie's article exposing Sebastian
Milton Pamela Milton is sick of all this
chanting outside her office so she calls
her secret police to round up a zombie
horde and send it at the Commonwealth
it's no big deal Mercer in the
Commonwealth Army can handle it but it
gives her an excuse to call a lockdown
so as Pamela Milton's trying to get her
son out of trouble Carol comes in like
hey I have an idea you just need a
scapegoat because outside our cruising
standoff with Lance Hornsby but now
Pamela comes to break it up and she
blames all Sebastian's crimes on Lance
Hornsby so our crew is saved but the
Commonwealth Revolution is stopped so
some of our crew are done with the
Commonwealth they're going back to their
various communities but others are like
hey the Commonwealth is our home now
we're going to stay and fight to make it
better especially Eugene with his lady
love Max who really wants to take the
militants down so as Sebastian's
rehearsing his Founders Day speech she
sneakily turns on the tape recorder and
it's like hey Sebastian tell me what you
really think and what he really thinks
is that the common people are dumb and
stinky and he doesn't like them so when
he gives a speech Max has her boyfriend
in the sound booth play the real tape
and people don't like it it sets off a
riot but in jail Lance Hornsby has a
scheme of his own he has some of his
loyal agents kill some workers so they
reanimate to zombies oh and now in the
chaos zombies eating everyone Sebastian
gets Max and pushes her into one but
Eugene comes in with the tackle and oh
zombie into Sebastian Milton and
absolutely don't feel bad for him he is
the worst but now with their son dead
Pamela Milton cracks it's like no more
Mrs nice Governor she's gonna come down
hard on Eugene for murder and Mercer's
going along with it to protect his
sister Max it's like look we gotta blame
it all on him so you you could live
she's like no way bro it's time to stand
up for what's right and fight Pamela
Milton but Mercer's not ready yet then
Pamela sends her secret police to kidnap
our crew it's only Daryl and Carol who
escape and have to rescue their friends
so they make a deal with Lance Hornsby
who's like yeah I know where your
friends probably are just get me out of
here they've probably been sent to
Pamela's secret forced labor camp it's
just down this way a bit follow the
train tracks but it's like well if we
could follow the train tracks we don't
need you to lead us there and Lance
Hornsby realizes he's made a huge
mistake goes to grab the gun but oh
Carol shoot some arrow in the neck and
that's where Lance hornsby's Journey
comes to an end and so our crews at the
labor camp where they've been working on
the railroad all the live long day and
turns out this new labor camp is at
Alexandria so planning an escape is two
unlikely allies neek and then King
Ezekiel right now negan's only priority
is his pregnant wife so when the
warden's like hey you turn in who's
plotting I'll give her better conditions
it looks like he gives up Ezekiel to be
executed but that was a fake out because
Negan gave himself up to keep hope alive
for his wife and the rest of the crew
but this warden's a dick he's going to
execute negan's wife too so now Ezekiel
and the rest of our crew have to get up
there like you'll have to shoot us all
this makes the Stormtroopers realize
maybe we're the bad guys and so as the
warden tries to escape oh Daryl stabs
him yeah the rest of the crew had snuck
in there to rescue him and so our crew
has liberated Alexandria but now it's
time to take the fight to the
Commonwealth inside the Commonwealth is
Eugene's trial where yumikos's defense
attorney but none of this matters the
judges paid off it's all a sham but
before he's found guilty Eugene makes a
final speech about standing up for
what's right and this finally gets
through to Mercer so instead of
executing Eugene Mercer sets him free
and it's like all right it's Revolution
time but I mean not right this minute I
gotta prepare gather troops loyal to me
but out there it's protest time again as
everyone knew Eugene was innocent so
Pamela Milton calls in another zombie
horde distraction meanwhile Aaron and
some others were taking the long way
home when they run into some zombie
troubles and wait what's this one's
opening the door oh snap it looks like
we got some Whispers here so Aaron pulls
off the mask but it's not a mask it was
a real zombie and we're finally doing
the zombies getting smarter thing then
they run into Luke who's been at
Oceanside with his girlfriend Jules and
fills him in that the Commonwealth are
the bad guys again so to hide from the
Stormtroopers our groups walking with
the dead and they end up in this horde
headed back to the Commonwealth they try
to take shelter in this RV but Elijah
gets swept away so Lydia grabs him these
do have a little romance going but as a
former Whisperer she should know better
because oh now a zombie bites her arm
luckily she's in here with Aaron the one
armed expert and it's like sorry girl
this is gonna hurt but Lydia is
amputated so the train group's talking
to Mercer he's gonna sneak him in but
now the zombie horde is coming he's
gotta go defend it it's like well I'll
call off some guards from the back gate
you can get in that way but now Pamela
Milton realizes Mercer is betraying her
so she has him arrested and when our
group sneaks in the train station oh
it's a trap
Pamela Milton herself grabs a gun goes
to shoot Maggie but little Judith Grimes
knocks her out of the way and I'll hold
you to this shot but with all the
Stormtroopers fighting our crew there's
no one dealing with the zombie horde
it's no big deal though I mean what are
they gonna do climb the walls but yeah
they don't know about these new variants
that's exactly what they do and the
zombie horde is swarming the common all
and this is very bad they try to make a
plan to save as much of the city as
possible but Pamela Milton pulls an
attack on Titan she's like no forget all
that all troops guarding the rich
people's neighborhood let the poor get
eaten and so our crews running for
safety but they find themselves on the
wrong side of the barricade and oh no
they're fighting for their lives Luke's
girlfriend Jules gets eaten and Luke
gets bit they get him to the hospital
and cut off his leg but it was too late
and R.I.P Luke elsewhere Rosita is
searching for her baby Coco goes into
beast mode and yeah saves her but now
her group is swarmed they're climbing
the pipes but Rosita now Falls that's
how she's back up that was a close one
but Rosita's a boss so now all of our
crew meet up together they break Mercer
out of prison and he's got friends who
get him in the back gate they go to
yumiko's Brothers doctor house and
finally operates on Jude crimes Mercer's
like hey guys the Commonwealth isn't
your problem you can all go home but
it's like no man the Commonwealth is our
home now we're ready to stay and fight
so it's time for the final showdown
Mercers like Pamela Milton you've been
bad you're relieved of Duty but she
still has all these loyal troops it
almost turns into a big fight but it's
Daryl Dixon who channels his inner crime
hey the living shouldn't be fighting
each other the dead or our enemy we
ain't The Walking Dead and so the
Troopers stand down they let the people
in the gates and Pamela Milton is under
arrest now we still have to deal with a
massive zombie horde but working with
the Commonwealth military our crew has a
plan fill the governor's mansion with a
ton of gasoline pour it all down the
sores lure the zombies in then boom Oh
epic explosion all the zombies are
incinerated and so the day is saved all
our crews having a happy dinner party
miraculously all the main characters
survived except actually Rosita's
looking sad turns out she was bit when
she fell and now it's a tearful farewell
R.I.P Rosita and Negan by the way is not
at the dinner party it still would be
weird but earlier he had a real heart to
heart with Maggie and he's been dancing
around It All season but never actually
said the words I'm so sorry Maggie's
like hey thanks for saying sorry I
accept you now as part of the group and
that you feel remorse and where you even
kind of get along but man every time I
look at you I still see you with that
bat killing my husband Glenn which is
never gonna be friends and so Negan
accepts that Redemption is not something
you get it's something you spend the
rest of your life working towards so
it's time to wrap things up as we check
in one year later the Commonwealth has
now reached its potential as a truly
good happy place with King Ezekiel
elected new governor Ezekiel Alexandria
is also thriving but it's not to happily
ever after Maggie's like look we're
doing great right now it's our duty to
go out there and help the right rest of
the world and so Daryl says his
farewells it's like look kids your
parents Rick and Michonne are still out
there somewhere I gotta go find them and
indeed Somewhere Out There Rick and
Michonne are still alive but it's not
just a voiceover Cameo because Rick
Grimes is here he showed up for the
finale he seems to be out on a wild
adventure wearing the jacket with the
three-ring logo of the helicopters that
took him away in fact he's escaped them
because now they've caught up to him
he's got to throw his supplies on this
boat which is where Michonne later finds
the phone with a picture on it and
indeed Michonne is back for the finale
too wearing a bomb ass new outfit riding
a horse hunting for Rick and so as the
helicopters recapturing him Rick Grimes
is smiling because he knows he's gonna
make it back to his family he and
Michonne and all the survivors say
they're famous line to each other we are
the ones who live and the show ends with
the kids Judith and Rick Jr who are
happy and safe at the Commonwealth The
Walking Dead began with the collapse of
civilization and a return to Primal
savagery but now our group has come out
of the zombie apocalypse on the other
side with a return to civilization and
working together we can build a bright
future and that's where the Walking Dead
comes to an end except it's not really
ending at all because we've got a bunch
of announced spin-off shows Maggie and
Negan team up once again in New York
their Show dead City and Daryl Dixon is
heading to France which we know from the
world Beyond is maybe where the zombie
apocalypse started so watch out for that
and of course Rick Grimes and Michonne
are confirmed coming back for their own
series which will finally explore this
mysterious Civic Republic and open a
whole new chapter in The Walking Dead
universe so there you have it The
Walking Dead main Series has come to an
end but it's time to celebrate with some
sweet official merch from The Walking
Dead shop I've got this quarter
subscription Supply Dropbox let's see
what's inside we're starting off the
winter box with a Walking Dead scarf oh
this is awesome it's got some iconic
Walking Dead logos on there uh winter in
style and the holiday fun continues with
an epic The Walking Dead snow globe oh
yeah check that out it's the classic
don't open Dead Inside yeah The Walking
Dead job's got a whole holiday section
Now find the perfect gift for The
Walking Dead fan in your life then we
got a figure it's a heads collectible uh
this is Merle yeah these are great you
can swap out the face so you got
actually six different looks in one you
got normal angry Merle or then boom
Walker Merle from when he comes back oh
man and of course we got this quarters
canvas art collection and this time it
is Big Bad Negan oh that's some awesome
artwork last thing in here is a really
cool exclusive if you love production
stuff they've got a page of the script
uh with the notes from showrunner Angela
King I love this kind of thing this is
sweet so click the link in the
description to head over to
thewalkingdeadshop.com sign up for the
subscription Supply Dropbox and get
exclusive merch every quarter and browse
the holiday section to pick up the
perfect gift for The Walking Dead Super
Fan in your life
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]